We're on problem number 7.
Ahmed has two containers of--
oh, look at that, they're
doing ethnic names now.
For the first time, someone on
the SAT sounds like they might
be related to me.
Anyway, Ahmed has containers
of two different sizes.
The total capacity of
16 containers of
one size is x gallons.
So let's see, so it's
container 1 size
and container 2 size.
So it's 16 containers of size 1,
so 16 times size 1 is equal
to x gallons.
And the total capacity of 8
containers on the other side
is also x gallons.
So 8 times c2 do is
also x gallons.
And x is greater than
0, of course.
You can't have negative
gallons.
In terms of x, what is the
capacity, in gallons, of each
of the larger containers?
Let me see what it is.
Ahmed has containers of
two different sizes.
The total capacity of 16
containers of 1 size is x
gallons, right.
And the total capacity of 8
containers of the other size
is also x gallons.
And x is greater than 0.
In terms of x, what is the
capacity, in gallons, of each
of the larger containers?
OK.
So all we have to know is about
the larger containers.
Oh, the trick here is which one
is the larger container?
Right, that is the trick
to this question.
So you really need 8 of the
second containers to get x.
We need 16 of this container
to get to x.
So this is a larger
container, right?
And if we wanted to know the
exact size, you divide both
sides by 8, you get container
2 is equal to x/8 gallons.
And you could have figured
out container 1 is
equal to x/16 gallons.
And something divided by 8 is
going to be bigger than
something divided by 16.
So this is our answer.
This is the larger container,
x divided by 8,
that's choice D.
Got to read these problems
carefully.
Next question.
Whoops.
Problem 8.
Rectangle a, b, c, d.
I'm still getting over the fact
that they had the name
Ahmed in the SAT.
Anyway, rectangle A, B, C, D.
One day, they'll have a Salman
in there too and I will be
very proud.
That's my full name.
I go by Sal.
Some people think that I'm not
proud of my ethnicity, but I
explained that's what
my mother called me.
But my full name is Salman.
It's actually Salman Khan, which
is the name of an Indian
actor that gets more
web hits than I do.
But that's life.
OK, problem eight.
Rectangle A, B, C, D, lies in
the x, y coordinate plane, so
the sides are not parallel
to the axes.
Well, let me clear this.
I have to focus.
OK.
It's not parallel to the axes.
What is the product of the
slopes of all four
sides of A, B, C, D?
Oh, this is fun.
OK.
So let me draw it.
So it looks like that,
like that, like
that, like that, roughly.
I didn't draw it perfectly,
but these are
right angles, right?
OK.
So let's say the slope of this
line, right here, is m, right?
Well this line's going to be
parallel to this line, so this
is also going to have
a slope of m.
And this is something you
should just memorize.
The slope of a perpendicular
line-- so the slope
perpendicular to this--
is a negative inverse.
So the inverse of m is 1/m,
and it's going to be the
negative inverse.
So the slope of this line right
here is negative 1/m.
And that's something that
you should just
memorize, for life.
And, of course, this one is
parallel to this one.
It's also perpendicular
to these two, so
it's also minus 1/m.
So they want to know the product
of all of these.
So you get m times minus 1/m
times m times minus 1/m.
m times minus 1/m, this is
minus 1 times minus 1,
which equals 1.
And that is choice D.
Next problem.
This problem is all based on,
did you know that the slope of
a perpendicular line is
a negative inverse?
Invert colors.
All right.
Problem number 9.
An hour long television program
includes 20 minutes of
commercials.
What fraction of the hour long
program was not commercials?
So if it had 20 minutes of
commercials, it must have had
40 minutes not commercials,
right?
So 40 minutes over an hour is
the fraction that's not
commercials.
So that's 4/6, which
equals 2/3.
That's the answer.
That's it.
Problem 10.
If the product of 0.3 and a
number is equal to 1-- 0.3 and
a number, the product of 0.3
and a number, I'll say x is
equal to 1.
So the product of 0.3
and x is equal to
1-- what is the number?
Divide both sides by 0.3.
x is equal to 1 divided
by 0.3.
And what is that equal to?
I don't know, can you use
a calculator on this?
You could multiply the top
and the bottom by 10.
That is equal to 10/3, which is
equal to 3 and 1/3, which
is equal to-- well, you could
just write 10/3, actually.
Multiply the top and
the bottom of it.
Well, that's also
3.333 repeating
over, and over again.
So you could do it
that way too.
Next problem.
Did I do that right?
Is equal to what?
Right.
That's right.
Problem 11.
Let-- oh, I like when they
define these new operations.
OK, this is a fun one, x y, z
can be defined as-- so that
means x to the y minus
z to the y.
For all positive integers x, y,
and z, what is the value of
triangle 10, 3, 5?
OK.
So what's x?
x is this term.
So it's 10 to the y-- y is this
term, 10 to the third--
minus z, z is this term.
I'm just pattern matching.
So that z is this.
And then my z to
the y, y is 3.
That's all it is.
So it's 10 to the third
minus 5 to the third.
10 to the third is 10 times 10
times 10, which is 1,000,
minus 5 times 5 times
5, which is 125.
And so that's what?
That's 875.
And we are done.
Next problem.
OK, draw a rectangle.
Let's see, they have a
rectangle that looks
something like that.
And then there's a line there.
And these are points P,
Q, R, S, T, and U.
And the figure above P, Q,
S, T is a rectangle.
And U, R, S, T is a square.
So this is a square.
Fair enough.
So that means this
side's equal.
P, U is equal to 5.
So this is equal to 5.
And U, T is a positive
integer.
U, T is an integer, So
that's interesting.
We know it's an integer, and we
know it can't be negative.
You can't have a negative side
of a square in our universe.
If the area of P, Q, S, T must
be more than 10-- so area is
greater than 10 and
less than 30.
Area is less than 30, so
we can write this way.
Area less than 30-- what is one
possible value of U, T?
Well let's just say that
U, T is x, right?
And this is a square, so
this is x, and this
is x as well, right?
And so what is the area
of this big thing?
It's going to be this
side which is what?
5 plus x times this
side, which is x.
So that's going to
be the area.
So it's going to be
5x plus x squared.
And so that's the area.
And it has to be between these
two spaces, right?
So we could try out
some numbers.
Let's see, if x is 1
what's the area?
It's 5 plus 1.
So then the area is 7.
No, that's not greater
than 10.
What happens if x
is equal to 2?
Then we have 5 times
of x is 2.
You have 7 times
2, which is 14.
And that satisfies
these conditions.
14 is greater than 10
and less than 30.
So that's it.
You didn't even have to do x.
You could have just said well,
what if x is, you could have
tried 1, and just tried 2.
And you could say 5 plus
2 is 7 times 2 is 14.
That meets my conditions,
and I am done.
That's all you've got to do.
I'll see you in the
next video.